hey leute bevor es losgeht noch eine
kurze ansage und zwar hab ich jetzt
gesehen dass auch schon andere youtuber
zu diesem thema comeback kommentieren so
ein video gemacht haben was sich
einerseits natürlich blöd finde weil es
mich doch persönliche betroffenheiten
dann sieht man das gleich auch bei
anderen dass so ein komisches gefühl
wenn man die eigenen gefühle
einzigartige so was aber auch unsinn ist
weil es ja so viel youtuber gibt die
alle in wahrscheinlich sehr gleichen
problemen stecken dass wir nächstes
absolut in ordnung und ich wollte
einfach nur sagen nicht dass er denkt
okay wir machen jetzt alle so videos
damit ihr das versteht das liegt etwa
daran dass sehr viele youtuber diese
probleme kennen und sehr viel youtuber
diese probleme haben deswegen
wahrscheinlich viele sich von diesem
video so angesprochen gefühlt haben das
ist heute ein bisschen ernsteres videos
heißt alle leute die auf vuitton oder
auch ernste ansagen oder auf sagt
nachdenken über sich selbst heute keine
lust haben absolut okay und jetzt filme
ab
hey leute
willkommen zum neuen video ihr habt
schon im titel des videos gesehen das
video soll sich heute um das video von
tadel drehen was er hochgeladen hat vor
einigen tagen ein wunder ist natürlich
dass das thema jetzt ziemlich geheilt
ist und der zweite grund ist aber und
das ist viel wichtiger für mich dass ich
einen persönlichen bezug zu einigen
punkten feststellen konnte die in seinem
video gemacht hat und deswegen weil ich
das einfach so machen wie ich sonst
immer mache wenn ich irgendein problem
ich spüre und zwar dass ich einfach dass
ausspreche und mal gucken was passiert
weil ich bin mir überhaupt nicht sicher
ob das video hier jemals auf youtube
landen wird weil ich einfach nur gerade
als ich sein video gesehen habe so ja
irgendwie bezug dazu herstellen konnte
mir dachte okay ich will jetzt darüber
ein video machen werden das sieht dann
habe ich mich doch dazu durchgerungen
bis hoch zu laden hat mir auf jeden fall
ein paar notizen zu seinem video gemacht
und möchte die jetzt einfach um mit euch
zu sprechen der erste punkt ist das tal
in seinem video anspricht dass er ein
erfolgreiches format hatte das war bei
ihm effekt und das sieht dieses format
vieles bei ihm verändert hat dazu kann
ich auf jeden fall auch in bezug
herstellen weil durch ein format was ich
gemacht habe die hacker schaudig main
kanal erst so bisschen weiterentwickelt
hat und da auch damals sehr schnell
gewachsen ist so über ihm so ein format
bisschen explodiert ist es bei mir auch
und wie gesagt die routine stellt sich
relativ schnell ein mann macht es
eigentlich nur noch für die klicks dann
irgendwann es einfach so dass viele
youtuber wenn ich sogar die meisten
youtuber einfach nicht jeden tag lust
haben ein video zu machen sich selbst
aber so unter druck setzt das jeden tag
ein video machen dass sie dann sich zu
videos zwingen und gerade wenn sie viel
zu tun haben nebenbei wie doch ich mit
meinem studium und den die welt
initiativen in denen ich mitarbeiter und
dann zusätzlich jetzt noch dazu mein
auto unfall da ist man schon ein
bisschen gestresst und dann hat man
teilweise auch gar keine lust videos zu
machen zwingt sich aber wenn man denkt
man muss irgendwie machen bei mir
persönlich ist es nämlich einfach so
dass ich und ich finde ich nicht dass es
gut ist aber mir ist dass ich irgendwie
schon stimmungsmäßig so ein bisschen
davon abhängig bin auch wie es auf
youtube gerade so bei mir läuft ist es
nicht nur dass ich meine ich aber noch
andere dinge im leben die mir wichtig
sind wie zum beispiel sportfreunde
studium das sind alles dinge die für
mich wichtig sind aber youtube hat auch
wenn man so viel zeit rein steckt und ja
wenn man sich dass es so eine
abwärtsspirale ist dann setzt man sich
selbst immer mehr unter druck und hätte
noch weniger lust und zwingt dich dann
noch wie es mache und die werden dadurch
wieder schlechter und die dinge sich
etwas mit dem los wieso macht ja nicht
mehr videos wie früher und ich hoffe
dass sich das jetzt auf meinem video
entspreche das irgendwie einfluss auf
mich hat auf euch halt dass ihr
vielleicht versteht was so in den
letzten monaten bei mir passiert ist
tadel sagt in einer stelle in seinem
video das er sich selbst damals
gezwungen hat wie es weiterzumachen weil
er einerseits das beibehalten wollte was
gerade lief was bruder seinem kanal lief
und andererseits angst davor hatte dass
zu verlieren sich deswegen gezwungen hat
auch wenn er keine ideen für videos
hatte und wenn er keine motivation bei
videos hatte und ja also ich sagen das
kenne ich sehr gut das kennen
wahrscheinlich auch sehr viele andere
youtuber sehr gut aber jeder hat eine
unterschiedliche persönlichkeit ich
mache es einfach sehr gerne aber so dass
ich mir die sachen von der seele reden
der kamera einfach drauflos andere
youtuber denken vielleicht auch so
machen ihr ding genauso weiter wie
vorher und sage gar nichts dazu
weil es einfach nicht der stil ist und
das ist auch vollkommen in ordnung
natürlich diese sache die er anspricht
videos zu produzieren und videos zu
produzieren das ist so ein ding das sich
sehr schnell einstellt gerade wenn man
sieht okay mit youtube geht's auf einmal
bei mir beck auch und ich kann auch
einmal wirklich geld verdienen also
keine ahnung aus dem nichts also
vierstellige beträge für irgendwelche
placement das ist ja für youtube
deutschland nicht mal viel es gibt auch
jede youtuber die fünfstellige beiträge
für places bekommen einfach so dann
denkt man sich so krass das ist jetzt
irgendwie dadurch möglich dass ich
videos machen das will ich auf gar
keinen fall verlieren auch wenn man
keine lust hat denkt was ich okay dass
jetzt fast so ein geschäft dann muss man
sich selbst zwingen ja das funktioniert
glaube ich nicht so wirklich wenn
youtuber das selbst als arbeits sehen
was am ende unterhaltung essen
unterhaltung muss halt irgendwo
unterhalten und positiv sein wenn der
der unterhalten soll also der youtuber
keine lust auf das hart wasser macht und
sich dazu zwingt dann kann es bei den
zuschauern die unterhalten werden wollen
eigentlich gar nicht ankommen es bringt
ja schon echt viel gras viele vorteile
mit sich die youtube videos zu machen da
kann man dinge erleben die man sonst nie
erleben würde als normaler bürger und
dadurch setzt man sich selbst natürlich
unter druck ganz großes problem dabei
ist natürlich auch dieses konzentrieren
auf zahlen ich weiß nicht ob man jetzt
vielen youtube analytics rumhängen
sollte also youtube entdeckt verdient
ist nicht wissen ist so ein tool das
haben youtuber unter kanal statistiken
zu seinem kanal auswerten wollen
richtig richtig krass die youtuber wie
ich selbst und auch wie viele viele
viele viele andere youtuber
untereinander also auf die klickzahlen
schauens ein botnetz möglichst gemacht
als ich das finde ich jetzt scheiße arm
ist warum sie meine klicks
runtergegangen das ist der punkt wo ich
momentan gerade bin und wo auch stimmt
er eine andere youtuber in deutschland
jetzt das geld nicht für alle sprechen
sagen dass vielen so geht oder den
meisten so geht das das kann ich gar
nicht das darf ich auch nicht aber ich
glaube es geht schon einigen soja so
dieses übertriebene achten auf zahlen
führte dazu dass so die zahlen das sind
was im mittelpunkt vor dem ganzen kanal
steht alles geht gar nicht mehr so darum
wie mache ich die beste unterhaltung
wenn er darum wie mache ich die meisten
klicks und dadurch auch wie verdient
hier meisten geld und das führt dann
dazu wenn man sich darauf konzentriert
dass man wenn es mal nicht so gut läuft
sich total schlecht für mir geht es
persönlich schon mal muss ich sagen und
ich glaube mich ist eine gute sache ist
aber es ist einfach so wenn ich zum
beispiel 45 stunden an einem tag in
video west ihre und ich dann sehe okay
das interessiert die leute gar nicht so
sehr das interessiert sie nicht so sehr
wie vorher
dann fühle ich nicht persönlich schlecht
denn wenn ich sauer ich meine es einiger
zumal man investiert lebensenergie und
zeit in diese sache und sie läuft nicht
so wie man sich es vorstellt und dann
ist man halt abgefragt wassergehalt
daher kommt dass man so auf zahlen
achtet aber es ist definitiv so dass ich
auch schon sehr viele emotionale und
persönliche momente auf youtube hatte
und dessen die momente die mir die
motivation geben quasi weiterzumachen
auch wenn man streckenweise irgendwie
nicht so viel sinn darin sieht und eins
von diesen videos war zum beispiel das
video was ich damals über meine
vergangenheit hochgeladen habe wo ich
erzählt habe wie es mir damals meiner
schulzeit ging und dass ich probleme mit
mobbing gehabt habe und so weiter und so
fort und darunter dann die kommentare zu
lesen von so vielen anderen leuten denen
es in dem moment nehmen sie das video
gesehen hat genau so ging es mir damals
ging also die quasi in dem moment in dem
sie das video gesehen haben wie er
situationen wollen der ich damals bei
der man sich total hilflos und scheiße
und kraftlos fühlt dass die leute ein
kommentiert haben gesagt haben okay mir
geht es momentan auch gerade so und dann
wird mir die kraft gegeben das war somit
einer der größten momente auf youtube
für mich dass es so ein gutes gefühl
wenn man da wirklich gesehen hat okay
ich habe leute da irgendwie was mitgeben
können für ihr leben und das ist ähnlich
unvergleichlich das kann man nicht in
geld aufwiegen
jetzt habe ich lange kreuz und quer
geplappert eine sache möchte ich noch
sagen zu abschlüssen zwar das bei mir
glaube ich das problem ist dass ich
genau in der mitte stehe ich bin nicht
dumm genug
kommt drauf zu scheißen was ich mache
und nicht darüber nachzudenken was ich
mache aber ich bin noch nicht konsequent
genug zu sagen okay ich mache jetzt
einfach mal drei monate lang keine
youtube-videos und konzentriere mich nur
auf die uni weil er meine angst aber zu
groß dafür ist was zu verlieren was man
sich bei so viele jahre aufgebaut hat
das heißt wenn man sich irgendwie
dazwischen aufhalten möchte also
zwischen so dumm zu sein das man nicht
selbst kapiert was man macht und
andererseits einfach so einen krassen
schnitt zu machen und einfach eine lange
pause zu machen oder gar auf zu hören
was ich auch nicht machen möchte gibt es
eigentlich nur eine möglichkeit und das
ist zu akzeptieren dass man in der mitte
steht und zu akzeptieren was man macht
wer mal in der mitte steht und das
möchte ich mit dem video machen ich habe
jetzt einfach mal die karten auf den
tisch gelegt ja an der stelle habe ich
dieses video glaub ja voraus falls es
jemals rauskommt ich bin sehr gespannt
wie er darauf reagiert dass zuschauern
dank fürs zuhören heute mal real tor bis
zum nächsten video gut leute